engage your defenses
and get this man a sheet
[Music]
fun isn't something one considers from
balancing universe
[Applause]
but this
does put a smile on my face
[Music]
hi to all our Weibo fans we are here
finally to answer your questions sorry
took a little while but we are hard at
work on these movies and we need a
minute we're here on set right now and
we've got our questions alright we're
gonna start with perot 11 asks could you
guys each pick a character that you
personally feel most excited about
revealing his or her character
development to us in the film without
spoilers can we know why you made this
pick okay I'm gonna start with fan OHS
I'm most excited for the audience to
learn about him I think it's very
interesting and complex villain that's
why I like them that's why I'm excited
for the audience to learn about him I
think his motivations albeit psychotic
are compelling and and I think that that
this in a lot of ways is his movie so
it's gonna be very interesting to see
how people respond to fans himself yeah
I would I'm gonna pick Thor because Thor
at the we're picking up his story
from the end of Thor Ragnarok and at the
end of that film as any fan would know
his home planet Asgard is destroyed and
so the character in is in a very is in
new territory so to speak because his
past has been torn away from him to a
degree and I think it was very similar
to Captain America's situation when we
picked up his story in Winter Soldier
when Joe and I came on to do our first
movie for Marvel
you know cap was in a place where we
were very much catching him up in the
modern world and seeing what that meant
to him and figuring out how you move a
character that far forward and that far
away from where they started back during
the 40s so I I think Thor we have
similar opportunities with that
character in this movie is that he's
gone through a radical transformation
and he's moving forward in a way where
he can never go back
and that's always a fun place to be with
a character as a storyteller right so
moany asks how do you define the hero's
fate or destiny there as we sacrifice
how will you Pappas get us to accept it
all right well I don't know about
getting you to accept it but I will say
this we love being told good stories and
we love telling good stories and all of
our energy and our effort and our
thought and our passion goes into
telling the best story that we can and
for us the best stories have stakes
people characters have to make
sacrifices
the the you know to really really feel
the true emotion and and the hero's
journey they have to go through trials
and those trials can cost them something
and so for us it's very important that
the heroes feel pain and that they make
sacrifices because I think that that not
only is a great storytelling but it also
is inspiring and I think we need a lot
of inspiration as well right now so I
think you know for us I don't know that
we if we can ever get you to accept it
but I promise you this we'll do our
damnedest to tell you the best story
possible and what you do with it from
there is is up to you okay we got our
last one here amp but these new arm is
super cool where's the inspiration come
from okay well this is not a spoiler by
me answering this question because in
the trailer we know at the exactly it's
in the trailer but also for everyone
who's seen Captain America Civil War
they know that Bucky was taken in by
achamma in Wakanda and so I think they
you know we catch back up with him after
he's been there for a while and if there
is an influence on his arm and may
perhaps have to do with that country
that he's been spending time in so
that's it
we really appreciate your questions
there were a ton of great questions it
took us a while to sift through them and
finds that find a few that we we wanted
to answer with that wouldn't give away
spoilers we are winding down here on
Avengers 4
we're almost done and that we're gonna
get the end up we remind Avengers three
and we're hopefully we're gonna deliver
you guys a great movie and a couple of
months here so thanks again thanks for
supporting and we'll talk to you soon
Happy New Year everybody so the Russos
are shutting the year down by dropping
some new infinity war talking about some
of the characters new armor where they
pick up and a lot of you been asking me
about particularly Captain America
because he has the new black panther
armor and technology as well as Thor
stuff so I wanted to focus more on
Captain America but I'll address all the
points that the Russos were talking
about like they say that they're
shutting down on Avengers 4 like they
did this QA from the set of Avengers 4
they finished filming that in January
but like spider-man Thor Captain America
Iron Man they're all still filming
scenes there's still a bunch of stuff
that's still going on right up until the
last day and that doesn't include any of
the post-production but because this is
just the tip of the iceberg and a bunch
of stuff is getting ready to drop be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
that's going on I'll explain at the end
of the video so Captain America being
granted Black Panthers boon get that man
a shield engage all defenses then you
see him running in the trailer with a
couple of Panther gauntlets that look
like they're taken right off of Black
Panthers old costume the really cool
thing is that because we have all this
black panther that's dropping we have
the footage of Sheree coming out as kill
mongers getting ready to throw down his
costume starts forming around him
you see Sheree bring her Panther
gauntlets up but you don't get to see
what they do just because they haven't
finished the CG on that the whole idea
is is there like a supercharged version
of the new energy costume that Black
Panther himself is wearing which we know
absorbs energy and helps him redirect it
when he chooses to so he can give off
energy pulses sure he can do the same
thing but her Panther gauntlets are way
more hardcore than the ones that Black
Panther himself is wearing she saves all
the coolest Black Panther tech for
herself so that's pretty much what's
going on with Captain America's Black
Panther gauntlets is that they absorb
energy so when he's fighting the
outriders here like this giant army of
CG villains he has the standard
vibranium Klaw so he'll be able to rip
through the outriders but also those
gauntlets will absorb force
helped create a shield for him so when
Black Panther says get this man a shield
it's sort of a wink because Captain
America uses a shield everybody knows
that but the gauntlets themselves or
sort of the weapon and the shield at the
same time so just a really cool
efficient use of technology he doesn't
have to carry around a shield and wear
the gauntlets he just has it all right
there
but in that QA they sort of stepped
around a lot of Thor's new weaponry in
his technology we did learn that this is
actually the space Forge but off to do a
separate video about his new weapon
because there's so much stuff that goes
into that but probably the funniest
answer that they gave was when they
talked about Thanos about how his
motivations are compelling even though
he's completely psychotic the thing
they're probably alluding to is the idea
that Marvel movies have had a problem
with death like characters just don't
die people are like how come there are
no stakes how can there be stakes
if characters don't die when they
followed up by saying the characters go
through trials they make sacrifices and
you know people might not be happy with
some of those sacrifices they're
probably talking about characters dying
during infinity war and them addressing
that during adventures for Captain
America is probably at the top of my
list there was actually an Iron Man
video that I was planning on making
because Robert Downey jr. was doing
separate interviews talking about his
relationship with cap in the movie so
you can kind of see where they're going
with it Iron Man might put all that
[ __ ] to rest
if he sees Captain America lay down his
life probably the last big thing is they
sort of confirmed that Winter Soldier
will get a vibranium arm like they say
you know what Conda inspired technology
which basically reads vibranium so
hopefully more characters in Avengers 4
will get some vibranium upgrades but let
me know in the comments what do you
think about all the stuff that the
Russos were saying during that Q&A and
if there are any bonus videos that you
want me to do in the next couple of days
just let me know in the comments right
now I'm working on my best of 2017 and
most anticipated video for 2018 so I'll
post those in the next couple of days
and for this week's Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway I want to try something a
little bit different so just use any of
the YouTube tools to share the video and
I'll say congratulations to last week's
winner Alexander please private message
me so I can get your contact details
click here for all of stanley's cameos
for his birthday and
here for that new black panther trailer
thank you so much for watching
Happy New Year everybody
[Music]